ومن خسا ينضم الينا عدنان ابو حسنه
المستشار الاعلامي لوكاله غوت وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين اهلا بك سيد عدنان
يعني هل توفرت ارقام تقريبيه حتى الان حول
يعني المفقودين من اللاجئين الفلسطينيين
المتواجدين في الاراضي المتضرره او
المناطق المتضرره على الجانب السوري ان
كان ضحايا المفقودين
نعم بصراحه ما حدث يعني حدث كبير
وجلل يعني حتى الان الجهود تبذل لايجاد
العشرات من الذين فلسطينيين المفقودين
ولكن هناك انباء تتحدث حتى الان عن وجود
يرمان نعرفه نحن في المخيمات مخيمات
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين الاربعه التي يقطنها
حوالي 62 الف لاجئ منهم 58 الف تضرروا من
هذا الزلزال هناك ايضا لاجئين فلسطينيين
من الجانب التركي ولكن نحن نتعامل مع
مخيمات اللاجئين التي يمكن الوصول لها من
دمشق لانه سوريا دوله مضيفه للاجئين
الفلسطينيين الحاجات كبيره هناك مفقودين
بلا بلا شك وارقام
القتلى في الجانبين من هنا ومن هناك
كفلسطينيين اكثر من شخص حتى الان حسب
احصاءات السلطه الفلسطينيه والسفير
الفلسطيني
الموجود في تركيا والموجود ايضا في سوريا
وكما عرفنا استاذ عدنان انه ايضا هناك من
لجا بفعل التضرر في مناطقه الى هذه
المخيمات يعني ممن لم يكونوا في المخيمات
وقت تضرروا كم الاعداد وما هي حاجيات
الاساسيه كم تستطيعون الصمود بما توفر لكم
من
اموال ومن مواد غذائيه وطبيه
يعني على سبيل المثال حوالي 700 لاجئ
فلسطين لجاوا الى مدارس ومنشات في منطقه
اللاذقيه ولكن نحن نتحدث عن 58 الف لاجئ
فلسطيني تضرروا الامكانيات هي امكانيات
بسيطه بشكل نحن اعلنا باننا بحاجه الى 72
مليون دولار تقريبا ثلاثه ملايين دولار
لتغطيه حاجات اساسيه نتحدث عن فراش اغطياب
بطانيات مواد غذائيه لدينا فعلا نحن في
مخازن مواد طبيه وبدانا في توزيعها ولكن
هذه المواد فتنسى ستنفذ حساب
يعني بالنهايه كمنظمه امميه يعني قد
يستغرق الامر عده اسابيع او اقل يعني
المخزون لم يكن لمخزونا بحجم هذه الكارثه
الكبرى التي اصابت المنطقه بس ثلاث ملايين
دولار يعني
تقدير نعم هذا تقدير مبدئي نحن نتحدث الان
عن مساعدات عاجله تتعلق باساس اساسيه
تتعلق بالطعام تتعلق بالفراش بالاغطيه
بالتدفئه يعني امور بسيطه للغايه ولكن بعد
ذلك سيتم تطوير هذا النداء طيب سيد عدنان
يعني التنسيق مع الجهات ان كانت الرسميه
السوريه او المناطق الخاضعه لسيطره
المعارضه السوريه على اي مستوى يحصل يعني
على اي نقاط يتم الحديث والتنسيق
هناك تنسيق كبير مع الدوله السوريه لانه
سوريا هي الدوله المضيفه يعني تتحرك نحن
تحت حمايه ورعايه الدوله السوريه ولكن
بالنسبه لاجئين الفلسطينيين الموجودين في
الجانب او المناطق التي تسيطر عليها تركيا
او وما الى ذلك والتي لا نستطيع الوصول
اليها هناك منظمات امميه عديده كل منظمات
الامم المتحده تعمل الان في تلكون معها
لا نحن ننسق بصراحه في الجانب السوري الذي
مع الحكومه السوريه ولكن هناك هناك مفوضيه
نعم هناك المفوضيه العليا اللاجئين الصحه
العالميه اليونيسف الجميع يعمل في تلك
المناطق
هل يمكن يعني الى اي ماذا يمكن ان تلعبوا
دورا
كنونروا في الداخل السوري في العلاقه مع
المنظمات الاوروبيه والامريكيه والدوليه
التي لا تزال لا تتعامل مع يعني كحكومات
اقصد لا تزال تتعامل مع النظام ولكن ستمرر
كل شيء عبر المنظمات هل لكم دور في هذا
الاطار
نعم نحن على اتصال يعني نحن اصلا ميزانيه
الودر ومن الدول المالحه ليس مهما علاقه
او غير علاقه نحن منظمه امميه تعمل بتفويض
لخدمه 438 الف لاجئ فلسطيني في مناطق
الدوله السوريه هناك الاف وعشرات الالاف
في المناطق الخارجه عن سيطره الدوله
السوريه ولكن نحن نتعامل مع دول المانحه
نتعامل مع المنظمات امميه منظمات حكوميه
وغير امميه ولا نجد حرجا والامور يعني لا
نجد فيها صعوبات كثيره الدوله السوريه
تتفهم بوضع الاونروا يعني لا نجد عقبات في
العمل في سوريا يعني يمكن ان تقوموا بمثل
هذا الدور
بالتاكيد بالتاكيد يعني نحن نشدنا المجتمع
الدولي بان يقدم لنا خدمات يقدم لنا
تمويلا عاجلا وبعد هذا التمويل سيكون هناك
تمويل اخر وتطوير هذا النداء حتى تتضح
الصوره تماما يعني الان كل الفراق على
الارض تقيم ما الذي ما الذي حدث ولكن نحن
نؤكد بانه من 62 الف لاجئ فلسطيني موجودين
في اربع مخيمات في شمال سوريا هناك 58 الف
لاجئ تضرروا من هذا الزلزال يعني نتحدث
اكثر
متضرر فلسطيني ما اولوياتكم يعني من اجل
الدعم الذي تطلبونه
يعني الكل يعرف انه هذه المخيمات ايضا
اثناء الحرب السوريه تعرضت الى ضرر كبير
يعني مخيم النيره يعني هو دمر والان جائز
زلزال ليدمر ما تبقى من هذا المخيم وبقيه
المخيمات الحاجات الاساسيه الان نتحدث عن
فراش عن اغطيه عن ادويه عن مواد غذائيه
ولكن الحديث عن اعمار المخيمات هذا سياخذ
وقتا طويلا ويحتاج الى تمويل اكبر ولكن
نعم اليوم نحن نتحدث عن انقاذ هؤلاء الناس
عن تقديم مساعدات اوليه له شو طبيعه
التضرر اللي صار ل58 الف استاذ عدنان
لن نتحدث عن مئات البيوت التي تضررت على
المنشات الاونروا ايضا التي اصيبت باضرار
كبيره يعني في النهايه في على سبيل المثال
في اللاذقيه في مخيم اللاذقيه الناس لم
تجد الى اين تذهب فذهبوا الى احد مدارس
الاونروا وهذه اعاده وتكرار لتجربه غزه
يعني استخدام المدارس
كملاجئ ويتم الان تقديم المساعدات الاوليه
يعني البعض لجا الى مدارس الاونروا التي
هي ليست كثيره الباقون هل من معلومات اين
هم متواجدين هل من ماوى هل من خيم
تستضيفهم
لا حتى الان بصراحه لا يوجد مثل هذه
الاشياء ولكن البعض عند اقاربه بعض البيوت
دمرت جزئيا بعض الناس موجودين بها وهكذا
البعض ترك المنطقه الى مناطق اخرى ولكن
الغالبيه تنتظر المساعدات التي ستقدمها
والدوله السوريه وغيرها من المؤسسات هل
هناك ايات وعود وصلتكم بشان الحاجه
للملايين الثلاثه الان
لا نحن اطلقنا اليوم اطلقنا اليوم هذا
النداء نتوقع خلال الساعات والايام
القادمه ان يكون هناك استجابه راينا يعني
نوع من الاجماع الدولي والحشد الدولي سواء
الاقليمي العربي او الحشد الدولي بالنسبه
لمحادثه في تركيا وسوريا وهذا يعني شيء
جيد يسهل عمليات الحصول على التمويل نامل
ان نحصل على هذا التمويل في اسرع وقت
السيد عدنان سؤال الاخير لحضرتك يعني هل
هناك
نيه لارسال كوادر بشريه ربما للمساعده
بعمليات الانقاذ ويعني او ربما القيام
بمسح شامل على الارض حول اوضاع اللاجئين
الفلسطينيين هل لديكم هذه القدره او النيه
القدره الماديه طبعا
نحن بالنسبه للطواقم طواقم الاونروا كلها
متواجده وتعمل على يعني لمساعده الناس في
هذا الاطار ولكن الحديث عن بنى تحتيه
متهالكه عن وضع اقتصادي صعب
والحرب السوريه التي دمرت دمرت الكثير
يعني هذا زلزال اضاف لمعاناه جديده غير لا
تستطيع بصراحه الاونروا القيام بهذا الدور
لوحده يجب ان يكون هناك
تجمع كبير سواء المنظمات الاماميه او غير
امميه ودول في الاقليم وغير الاقليم تعمل
لمواجهه هذه الماساه الكبرى التي تعرضت
لها سوريا شكرا جزيلا لك استاذ عدنان ابو
حسنه مستشار العالمي لوكاله وتشغيل
اللاجئين الفلسطينيين من غزه تحياتنا اليك